(audience cheering and applauding)
- (screams) Like, the
coolest perk of this job, PS,
is getting to meet
people you never thought
you'd get to meet,
and then you get to talk to them,
and get paid for it.
It's awesome.
- I am so glad to come
and visit with you.
- You know, I am such a fan.
- I love and adore you.
- I think you're so talented,
you're so talented.
I love like everything you're in.
You actually know JadaSlayy, I heard.
- I do where,
ooh, my beautiful lady.
(indistinct)
Ooh, so inspiring.
- How do you know her,
how do you?
- We worked together
on "9-1-1".
- Oh, that's right,
that's right.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I'm sorry,
it's just hard, yeah, yeah.
- Oh, my gosh.
- So good to me,
so good to me.
I'm so (indistinct).
- Have you been able
to see a drag show in person?
- I've not,
so I mean I've seen pictures,
but to see it in the flesh is exciting,
I love it.
And we talked about,
you know, she would show me videos,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- but would you show me that jump, split,
- [Jada] Of course.
death, drop?
- What's that?
(Angela laughing)
- I will, I will for you, mama. (giggling)
(audience cheering)
- [Angela] You give me a little of that?
- Okay, let me show you.
- And you can do it in that outfit,
in those heels.
- Are you about
to make me feel bad about myself?
- Ready, here we go.
- What?
(Angela cheering)
(audience applauding and cheering)
(Angela laughs and claps)
(audience cheering)
- Ow!
(Angela laughs)
Oh my God.
(Angela clapping)
- My thighs.
- I actually, your thighs.
Oh my God, I hurt like just watching that.
- I feel you.
- Oh my God,
that was amazing.
- I did that in high school once,
and that was the last time for me,
so thank you for that. (laughs)
- I have never done that,
and I probably never will.
- I wanted her to do it on "9-1-1."
- I would literally have
to have so much alcohol
and a doctor for afterwards.
(Angela laughing)
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like I-
- I would be
like, "Tylenol please." (laughs)
- That was amazing.
- Thank you.
- Yeah, and a heating pad that would hurt.
So wait, I have to ask,
I heard that your first ever
concert was pretty amazing.
You wanna tell everybody who that was?
- First ever, oh, what
a come around moment
with the Jackson Five.
- That's amazing.
- [Angela] Yes.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] Somebody told me that,
'cause I always ask,
'cause obviously, I'm a musician,
so I always ask like what people go see
and that's your first concert?
- Yes, and my sister and
I were in North Carolina.
My poor uncle, he had gotten us tickets.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they got great tickets,
'cause we were in like
the first or second row.
- What?
- We had our little,
you know, Bolero jacket,
- You were ready.
- hot pants,
and Samson and Delilah sandals,
(Kelly laughing)
and I swear, they looked
right at me and sang the song,
and it was just great.
And then many, many, many
years later when I decided
to become an actress to play
Miss Catherine, their mom.
- Oh my God, wow.
- And she's an absolute delight,
- What a full circle.
- delight.
- Yeah.
- And I remember being
at the Image Awards and
Miss Catherine walked by,
and it was like,
and we would sit and have lunch,
and look at the clouds and talk,
such a mother.
- Yeah.
- Such you know, an inspiration,
and so she stopped and Michael,
and he turned around like, "Mom,"
and he came back and he was like,
"Oh, you were wonderful."
- Oh, that's so nice.
- And I was that 12 year old
all over again, (laughs)
- Isn't that crazy
when stuff like that happens?
- and it's brought me back.
I was just like,
"Oh my God, his hand is in my hand."
- Oh, that's so cool,
and I just can't say it enough,
it's a very rad first concert.
(Angela laughing)
I was like, I don't know
if anybody can beat that,
but wait so you were just
in Puerto Rico, right,
with your sister?
- [Angela] I was just there,
my sister and my cousin.
- Yeah.
- It was actually one of her,
her job, they had raised enough,
done great things,
so they were being awarded by their CEO-
- Oh.
- Janice Howard Bryant.
- Okay.
- Greg Bryant Howard.
- And just appreciating all the hard work.
They were glorious group of people,
and I sort of like,
pinched off their vacation.
- [Kelly] Tagged along?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I will never mind being
that third wheel. (laughs)
- I had a great time with ATV,
and I had never done that before.
- You've never been ATV-ing?
- I've never been A-
- That's like one
of my favorite things to do in life.
- Really?
- Yes.
- My sister was like,
"You're supposed to follow the guide".
I was going around the mud puddles,
you know going very slowly through them,
because before going everyone
had splatter and mud,
and everything,
- Yeah.
- and I had sandals on,
and white and-
- I'm the girl that
came back from that ride
that you saw before you went out,
and you're like, "What happened to her?"
'Cause I'm the one that
hits all the puddles.
- [Angela] Yeah, I didn't know.
- I'm like, "Well, I wanna get closer."
- I didn't know we're doing that.
- But I do think they go so fast though,
'cause I've done those tours,
and I'm like,
"You go too fast.
I wanna see it."
They go, yeah.
- They go fast,
and they're heavy,
and you're just turning,
you're you know, fishtailing,
- I love it-
- and it's a little scary
on a straightaway, a straightaway.
I mean I'm Mary owned ready, but.
(both laughing)
- No, I love that you did that though.
It's so fun and it's seem so beautiful.
- Zip lining in the rainforest.
- [Kelly] Oh wow.
- You know, some of the guys on, you know,
couldn't speak,
I speak a little bit of Spanish.
For me, you know, (speaking in Spanish).
- Oh my God.
- So, ola papi. (laughs)
- Like if you couldn't be hotter,
you had to start speaking
in another language.
- I know, but I had to
give him a little bit
because their little coconuts,
- [Kelly] God.
- and they came up to
my cousin and sister,
and he had a machete and
he opened the coconut,
- That's hot.
- and gave it to 'em,
- Yeah.
- and somehow the language barrier,
(Kelly laughing)
you know, just poof.
(Kelly laughs)
I was like thank you.
- So sexy man with a machete,
"You wanna a coconut?"
- Yeah, you got two more?
(Angela laughing)
That was a look at her
show, "9-1-1" on Fox,
so what's up with your
character this season?
- Athena and Bobby, you
know, this of course,
this your gore, and action,
and mayhem, and drama.
The first part, you know,
in the fall we left off,
so it's a lot of family stuff.
You know, May has been
working as 911 operator.
Her gap year is over,
what's she gonna do?
- Yeah.
- Mom's trying not to, you know,
insert her opinion too strongly.
- Yeah.
- You know, but Athena
and Bobby are doing great,
and there's this,
you know, we based a lot of our stories
on real life issues, situations,
- Yeah,
- symptoms, all of that,
- which is why it's relatable.
- and it's called fear-o-phobia.
- Yeah.
- And so there's a condition,
where one of our characters,
she absolutely has no fear.
You know, she douses a man in gasoline.
She's at the top of, you know, a station,
she's about to jump.
It just doesn't register,
and I'm trying to talk
her down and save her.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
So it's some sort of blood condition,
and it goes to the brain.
- I've never been thankful
for my fear.
- (chuckles) What's your fear?
- I don't,
- What's your biggest fear?
- oh God, I have like,
- Don't say men.
- I think as a mother,
it's always your children,
if something happens to your children.
But like just in life,
I don't really wanna say it,
what if some psycho takes
me and like does it to,
I don't wanna say it.
I don't wanna. (laughs)
- Is somebody snatching you?
- Maybe somebody kidnapping
me and then do my worst fear.
No, I'll just say it,
I don't wanna be stranded
in the middle of the ocean,
just sitting there treading water.
- Ooh, ooh.
- I'd rather the shark
just come and eat me and get her done.
(crowd laughing)
- Oh, no, no. (laughs)
- You know, just take me out like,
'cause I can tread water for a while.
- I don't know,
I had never been on a
cruise before, first cruise,
so like, we're out here in
the middle of the ocean.
- [Kelly] Yeah, and we all
know about the Titanic.
- And I was like. (sobs)
- Yeah.
- I had to just like.
- First thing I do
is check for boats,
- Yeah, mm.
- so are there enough for all of us,
or what's happening?
- Yeah, mm-hmm.
- Yeah, yeah, I don't like being
in the middle of the ocean.
- Mine is being,
I don't like being closed in,
so like claustrophobia a little bit.
- No.
- And I remember one time
working with Wes Craven,
you know, "Scream,"
- Yeah.
- and all of that
like the king of horror,
- Yeah.
couldn't be a nicer man.
And he had me in a coffin, you know,
but fortunately it was one of
those with a top and a bottom.
I was like, "Please,
leave the bottom open,
so that my mind knows I
have way out." (chuckles)
- Oh, do you,
I actually am claustrophobic.
I get claustrophobic, yeah.
I never had it until I was like older,
and it happened when I
was in a pyramid in Egypt,
and all of a sudden I was like,
"There's not enough air for all of us,
and I'm gonna make it."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So (laughs) I race outta that thing,
pushing women and children out of the way.
- Right, I was in that thing,
what's that place?
The Notre Dame,
Notre Dame in Paris,
- Oh.
- and you know it's an old building,
so it's just like you're walking-
- [Kelly] Oh, the stairs.
- the stairs.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And these little windows,
and you're like,
"I wish I was at the
cafe having cappuccino."
(audience laughing)
- Yeah.
- Why am I going up here
to the gargoyles?
- Yeah, I-
- And people are walking
slowly and you're like,
"Come on."
- No, and there's
not enough air.
- I ran down, yeah.
- Yeah, no, I look at the stuff like that,
and I'm like so happy I
was born when I was born
when I was born,
(both chuckling)
I'm like, I would not have
made it in Medieval times.
Wait, I wanna ask about
"Black Panther Two."
First of all, ah, just amazing films,
but will the queen get to
fight in this next one?
Because I want you to.
(audience laughing)
- Really?
- Come on.
- Oh, she's got sure strength.
- Yeah.
- She's a got, ooh.
(audience applauding and cheering)
Ah, with Chadwick.
(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] It's literally like,
that is one of the films
that's seen most in my house.
- I'll use my face here.
- My five year old son is obsessed.
- Really?
- He's obsessed.
Every Halloween he wants
to be Black Panther.
- Aww, I love that.
- Yep, every Halloween.
It's so cool.
- I love that.
- And it's cool to like,
I know it's a superhero thing,
but it's cool that like, you know,
to be able to be a
character in these movies
that these kids will grow up just loving
and you get to be a part of,
that's such a cultural thing
that so not many people
get to be a part of.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
- Queens and Kings, queens.
- Yeah.
- You see that representation.
- But also like representation
and also good messaging,
like you know, it's one step further,
I think from when we were kids like.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, I think it's really-
- I really give a lot up to our director
and our writer, Ryan Coogler.
- It's so good.
- I mean, he's such,
such a tremendous talent,
and everyone that he brings on that set,
everyone in front of the
camera and behind the camera,
so impressive and giving
a thousand percent
- Yeah.
- of their gifts,
and we all have gifts.
- Team player, yeah.
- So it's a beautiful place.
- Oh, the cast is insane.
- Mm-hm.
- Yeah, it's like
you've see the cast and you're like,
"Okay, play."
(Angela laughing)
It's so amazing.
So what memories of Chadwick do you have,
do you have any great ones?
- Ah, let's say, what was,
maybe about 15 years ago,
I was given, thankfully,
grateful for honorary PhD
from Howard University.
- Oh, wow.
- Yeah, so I went there.
(audience applauding)
- That's amazing.
- Thank you, thanks,
(audience applauds)
and he was my guide.
He was my student guide.
- [Kelly] Wait, like before he was acting?
- [Angela] Before anything and everything.
- [Kelly] Are you serious?
- [Angela] Yeah, he was an actor there.
He was an actor there, yeah.
- What a full circle moment.
- Mm-hm, mm-hm.
- Did he tell you that
whenever y'all were?
- He told me that at the opening party,
at the premier party,
and I was like (gasps) you
could hold water. (laughs)
You can, (laughs)
- Wait.
- I can't hold water, you know,
but yeah-
- He didn't tell you
the whole time you were filming?
- And we sat next to
each other every morning
in the makeup chair,
you know, as were getting our lines,
and our accents,
and our work together for the day,
and he was just so amazing,
- Oh my gosh.
- and he reminded me of that.
- I would've had
to have been like, (mumbles) we've met.
- Mm-hmm, me too, me too.
- Yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
That's so cool though.
I love those full circle moments.
That's really, really cool.
- Amazing, amazing man.